يتم ضمان علاقة دور USS
من خلال
التزام الولايات المتحدة بأمن إسرائيل بأن هذا
الالتزام غير قابل للتفاوض ،
فمن الواضح أن التوسع الاستيطاني Ironclad [موسيقى] يمثل
عقبة أمام أفق الأمل الذي
نسعى إليه
[موسيقى]
أي تحرك نحو ضم الغرب  قام
البنك بحكم الواقع
بتعطيل الوضع التاريخي الراهن في
الأماكن المقدسة ، واستمرار عمليات
هدم المنازل وطرد
العائلات التي عاشت في تلك
المنازل لأجيال ، مما
أضر بآفاق الدول
[الموسيقى]
الأجنبية [
الموسيقى]
الأجنبية
[الموسيقى]
استنادًا إلى عام 1967  سطور
تبادل الترحيب المتبادل تظل أفضل طريقة لتحقيق
هدفنا المتمثل في أن يعيش الإسرائيليون والفلسطينيون
جنبًا إلى جنب مع
تدابير متساوية من الحرية الأمنية والفرص
والكرامة
[موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سنواصل الإعراب عن دعمنا
لـ  المبادئ الأساسية للديمقراطية بما في ذلك
فصل السلطات والضوابط
والتوازنات والمساواة في إقامة
العدل لجميع مواطني إسرائيل